the Bolden era of firing line was really
like 1966 for the first 15 years
that's when Buckley had like Eldridge
Cleaver on the mainstream wouldn't put
on television it was the only place I
could get any airtime my absolute
favorite is his introduction of Clare
Boothe Luce he introduces her in a way
that she determines is chauvinistic and
in her response to his first question
she completely undresses him in the
entire introduction there was only one a
masculine put them what you've got from
Buckley was that he really had a rapport
and respect for his guests even though
he disagreed so there was really a
camaraderie and a collegiality and a
respect for the ideas few TV shows
especially few political shows can
compare to firing line the talk show
hosted for decades by William F Buckley
being evasive a lot of it in its
original incarnation it ran for 33 years
and over 1,500 episodes and it featured
guests ranging from Muhammad Ali to
Ronald Reagan to Jack Kerouac to Milton
Friedman to mother Teresa these things
Jesus just don't kissing me the show
went off the air in 1999 but now it's
back on PBS and I'm pleased to sit down
with the new host Margaret Hoover I'm
Margaret Hoover and welcome to firing
life born in 1977 Hoover is the
great-granddaughter of Herbert Hoover a
former contributor to Fox News and CNN
and the author of 2011's
American individualism how a new
generation of conservatives can save the
Republican Party Margaret thanks for
talking to reason thanks for having me
what is it like to occupy the seat that
William F Buckley famously slouched on
for 30 plus years I need to light my
cigarette before I can answer that
question yeah there was a lot of there
was a lot of smoke in their pipes there
were cigars or there's no Nicorette
thing you can do to refuse it
look I the first thing I tell people is
like I'm not trying to be Buckley
because I'm not like I'm not willing
that Buckley he had run for mayor by the
time he launched firing line in fact it
was his mayoral run he was 40 years old
he ran for mayor of New York City
created the Conservative Party in New
York and written got a man at Yale
and founded a small conservative Journal
that nobody really read at least at that
point so we're very different people but
what he did was create a tradition on
television that was a rigorous contest
of ideas and that has gone missing and
so the goal is to bring that tradition
back inspired by him into really respect
that legacy I'm somebody who comes by
legacy honestly and I appreciate that
there are there are a lot of people who
care deeply about the tradition and the
legacy that William F Buckley left
behind and I want to approach it with
kid gloves because I understand that
legacies are important what are the big
ideas that you think need to be
discussed that are you know that have
kind of gone missing there are sort of
big ideas like the the challenge of the
moment I think is sort of the ideas that
define and need defending in the context
of Western democracy and liberal
democracy and I think there are so
that's like I mean free speech and open
society and free press and freedom of
religion sort of all the sort of the
foundational pillars of you know the
Bill of Rights I think that there are
just policy issues we need to talk about
Lee we have an opioid crisis in this
country why do we have an opioid crisis
what are the problems that are
perpetuating that what are the systemic
failures aside from sort of the ailing
x' that we have societally like we have
ailing is in our government you know
there's a I think a real failure in
Congress everything there's a lot of
sort of policy issues and sort of
problems that we can tackle there are
cultural problems and so you know
there's there's this sort of moment we
have where we can I think sit back and
reflect and unpack in a in a long format
an exchange with people who are really
experts in those areas to sort of think
through how we solve our problems and
the best part is we have this archival
repository of 1,500 episodes where many
of the same problems
Buckley took on and so in many cases
we'll be able to will use firing line
clips in the show to demonstrate that
the arguments are the same they were the
same 40 years ago and 30
twenty years ago or in some cases
they're totally different you identify
as a conservative and and Buckley you
know at various points would use the
adjective libertarian but he was you
know he created the modern conservative
movement or was the kind of godfather of
it
what um what did what do you see is the
essential difference between
conservatives and libertarians it seems
to me that the modern American
conservative movements tenants when
Buckley formed sort of the the initial
cohesiveness and then with the fusion
ISM after Frank Meier write it there was
this tenant of traditionalism which
wasn't really the white evangelical
southern Protestant tradition yet I mean
that came later in the eighties but when
when you sort of at the formation in the
sixties in the 70s so there was this
traditionalist component it really stood
against a secular state so that that's
one element of conservatism I think but
I think when it comes to sort of free
market ideas and sort of free-market
libertarianism I think that was one of
the other components of Buckley's
philosophy I think that that's where you
got a lot of common cause of
libertarians and then you know the other
fundamental sort of denominator and the
conservative movement was this it was
anti-communism and that the libertarians
as they emerged sort of later didn't
really need to take a strong stand well
now we don't as resolved it to us or had
resolved itself that way yeah in 2011
the the book that you wrote or the book
that you published the subtitle was or
it was book about saving the Republican
Party you know it's seven years later
I'll stand by everyone and it's totally
irrelevant I'm not trying to save it
from then and then what are you doing is
it worth saving now I mean so the title
was and I'll do this later
because I always go down the Herbert
Hoover buddy home but the title was
American individualism which was a title
of my great-grandfather's first really
concise articulation of his view of
American exceptionalism what made
America great the subtitle was you are
tearing up just thinking about that
aren't you yeah I'm so transparent I
have no poker face how the next
generation of concern how a new
generation of conservatives can save the
Republican Party that was that was a
subtitle so the idea was there are
there's a whole generation of
Millennials who by the way when I wrote
the book it was 2010 that first data was
out on millennial
and by the way they'd also helped just
recently elect Barack Obama really been
a critical difference in his election
and so the you know Kai and I had just
come out of the bush White House and I
had seen
yeah there and there was a we were very
very polarized and it was a very very
intimate office with last time record
low ranked 21 23 percent recuperating so
the idea was all right we're we're not
gonna win this next generation unless we
start making the case about our ideas
and by the way we can't even lead with
the are on the title wait but we do need
to start making the case for our ideas
to this group and so the idea was you
know to the book buying community of
conservative book buyers which is what
this book was cast as here's who the
Millennials are and iceberg ahead you
know we need we need to try to figure
out how to win or else as we know in two
or three presidential cycles if a cohort
votes for the same party multiple times
by the third time
they're never gonna self-identify with
that other party they're just not and so
that it was intended to be a warning a
clarion call it would canario just sped
it up the canary died okay well I it is
really overtaken by events I mean the
Republican Party has is irreparably
damaged with the Millennials but at the
same time the Republican Party holds and
you know this may change in in the fall
but I mean it holds a record number of
congressional seats and Senate seats and
governorship and they're not women and
they're not minorities and they're not
the I mean it's where are the ideas that
the Republicans should be sowing that
would actually appeal to those groups
well I do think equality equality of
opportunity for all Americans
right and I do I mean all the things I
said exactly I'm just gonna remake the
are just have a look right I do think we
need to recognize that the country is
getting more diverse not less diverse
and I don't you know I don't think we
need to double down on either
isolationism or sort of the the
old-world the millennial generation is
40 percent non-white and you think is
that with the Republicans is that as
much I mean because equality equality of
opportunity you know women have made
leaps and bans and will continue to
minorities as well and is it more that
there's a sense among people I mean I'm
not a Republican I'm an independent but
you know I get a sense that they're
really uncomfortable with the idea of
like oh if you say
equality of opportunity or women can do
this job like they're gonna roll their
eyes like even the women who identify as
Republican is it a sensibility more than
actual policies or well I mean I guess
when I said equality laughter I was
still thinking about LGBT equality as
well because that's a that's a key
social issue that sort of is a litmus
test for people like are they
inspiration immigration and you know I'm
all for having an immigration policy
that's comprehensive but like let's have
low-skilled workers coming it's okay to
have a little skill workers come into
the country and fill jobs and that's not
so how much longer are you gonna be in
the Republican side so here's my you
know I sort of evaluate this daily I'm
not one of these commentators that
really likes to go do a victory lap and
make a new cycle out of myself saying
I'm leaving the Republican Party I sort
of consider myself in exile
right like I don't understand the
Republicans that I see in Congress now I
don't look up to them I don't admire
them there's very few of the other
couple they're a couple
I like Carlos Cabello a lot I like Mike
Coffman I you know I think there are
some that are trying to do the right
thing and are trying to be courageous
and stand up to Trump without completely
you know destroying themselves
politically but are authentically
articulating the ideas that I believe in
and they by the way need defending right
now and from exile you can try to tinker
from the outside and and hope that you
know hope that the regime topples and
that you can go back in and pick up the
pieces and remake it and I'm not
confident that's what's gonna happen
and so maybe you know maybe there is a
third way eventually I don't know what
the vehicle or the vessel is I'm not
wedded to the success of the Republican
Party at all costs you know it's I'm not
that tribal but there's a tradition
there that was a vessel for really
important ideas for a really long time
and that it may be over or it may not
but uh whether it is or isn't is gonna
have nothing to do it with the weather I
am still identifying with the party or
not we'll leave it there we've been
talking with Margaret Hoover she is the
host of the new reconstituted firing
line Thank You Margot for talking to
reason thanks Nick for reason I'm Nick
Gillespie
[Music]
you
[Music]